well as he said off the top of our
newscast here ted is out at liberty park
for a hispanic heritage event picked a
pretty good one ted because this could
be maybe our our farewell to triple
digits for a while huh
[Music]
hey denise yeah it's hard to hear you
right now but how great is it to see
outdoor festivals going on again here
especially in north las vegas for
hispanic heritage month uh mexican
independence day we're going to bring in
councilman isaac barron our good friend
here from north las vegas to tell us a
little bit about i'm told isaac that
this event
took a while to plan correct what
well you know of course we still have
time to call it so we always might want
to make sure that everything's covered
friendly and coping safe but of course
there's also a community event with a
lot of community resources including uh
cover protection with the southern
nevada health district hey come on down
this certain bad health has all three
versions of the uh of the uh uh the
vaccination you come down get vaccinated
and party with us and we usher in
hispanic heritage month and this event
happens to be the official grip
for the valley in other words the fiesta
the cry for
right here at liberty park in north
vegas well last year this is all virtual
right so how exciting is it to see it no
longer virtual people are out here
having a good time yes you know
of course you know everyone after a year
and a half of being uh shut inside the
public is clamoring to come outside we
i'm so happy that so many of our people
in the community have already gotten
fascinated with a few more to go but so
many have gotten vaccinated so we can
actually have it like this so i do urge
everybody come on out join us for
festivities get vaccinated if you
haven't and if you haven't met come out
anyhow we have lots of community uh
services hey we have we have alejandra
milian the the voice of coco from from
the very famous uh
oh yeah he's right over here we we're
gonna bring him in it's great all right
well thank you uh councilman bell thank
you so much i appreciate it great job
setting this up let's get to our
forecast right now first we're gonna
begin with air quality right now we're
gonna show this because we're back in
the moderate category guys you notice
that haze in the air is still out there
smoke for our forecast does show that we
are going to clear out some of that
smoke okay a little bit as we get into
uh the weekend so that's good this smoke
coming in also from california obviously
thickest haze of course is off in
california and uh portions of southern
south county but uh otherwise that haze
will start to clear tomorrow southwest
radar staying dry right now we got a
flattened ridge in the jet stream giving
us that zonal flow now here's what's
gonna happen we're gonna go to our winds
for tomorrow we're going to keep it
right here winds will pick up tomorrow
we'll become breezy again gusts up to 25
but the stronger winds will come later
on the weekend and yeah we've got some
big changes headed our way for next week
we'll have 80s
80s in the eight day forecast that's all
straight ahead back live now if you want
to come down and check it out you heard
councilman this is open all the way
until eight o'clock tonight remember at
four o'clock people were trickling in a
lot of people down here i've talked to a
few that are just having a great time to
be out again out in public again
and having a good time there are
resources here you can go to there's
food also and a place for the kids as
well this is a liberty park in north las
vegas come on down we're this is all
going on all the way until 8 o'clock
tonight reporting live here in north las
vegas and civic center drive ted
florento 8 news